but really the only reason that JD
starts even in here is because of fate
belong yeah that's definitely that's
definitely true majorly dominating his
group right and then you just had that
one loss to face bull all that put him
into this position so now he's on the
loser side of the bracket right chicken
ended up making it out on their winners
side if we just saw that match but here
we go
JD CR vs anikan a nanny-cam one of the
premier players in the world at this
point
Lincoln World Tour season for Anakin
this year has been nothing short of
stellar and I'm gonna tell you something
I've been saying it for the longest time
at the end of the Tekken World Tour
season last year in Amsterdam yes
Annika topi verbatim he said wait till
next year
wait till next year and look at where he
is he is in the top eight of the Tekken
World Tour Finals 2019 that's you he
stood up to his promise and look what it
did for him yeah unbelievable definitely
the best Anakin that we have seen to
date here is in the finals in the top
eight going up against JD CR alright
guys if you like JD CR to take the set
make some noise or if you guys won
redbull and it can it take it make some
noise
oh pretty splint and we're going to the
Mishima Building yeah alright I love
this song should I not sing it he's not
here he's not watching we're here let's
go I think you're not think so no yeah
okay oh he said it's cool I got it
uh-huh counter hit on the wall then
names the swamp right now but Ann can
get him beat up your Jay detail with
that dragon off and the dragon has been
so successful for him here today now to
once again Lowell Perry on the wall
working on a perfect soul part yeah many
gets it the perfect for JD tr
Conrade again with the one-to-one anakin
d'Alene to get up this time around
seeing JDC are being a little bit
offensive on top of it back to the
middle of the stage we go almost to the
wall but he drops the engine while Stan
yeah nice catches them out with the
float head back one the robot recline
are not gonna work Wow back swing both
so unchecked don't you look at the
possible over tip 10 you just took that
don't like flip for me do it anything
Jack's ever winning sleep mode he's like
I'm not moving at all you Anakin tying
it up here this is crazy oh look at the
president man just dashing in his face
you said JD CEO said he was gonna be
comfortable this is what most conquer
bitter not action uncomfortable you know
Jonathan you got to make them coming it
get all for me not that kind of robot go
now looking good once again this wall
pressure from JD cor Jack never connects
there's the one just pushing forward
jackhammer once again oh god oh such a
clutch block last second long and he has
boys enough Judah to close this one out
oh yeah this one should be easily done
for JD PR two rounds to one in this
first game JD CR is in the lead it's
stopping in for movement from Anakin Eli
can just rush up and scare you and see
what you're gonna do
JDC yards like I'm not taking that
anymore jackhammer they're off the check
roll keep the pressure going man does
such a great job of tracking jay-z our
side steps and that was one of the
things that may JT just such a threat to
anybody for the past three years
mm-hmm and he's using that Jack
long-wave job to keep James Harden check
as well jackhammer and the thing you got
to remember you're to JCR is probably
like has the most exquisite get Jack
more than anyone right exact 20 cards
estate for so long happen upon the legs
once again and there's always this
matchup don't know and that's the new
change I forgot to hide 100 love that
one stand up
that was the track beautiful lip punish
Joe two rounds apiece Anakin versus
Jamie see y'all back in forth the lasers
going off in the background looking good
so far
these big toe to toe against the arc oh
look you love it closer to their wall
Russian why do it out there right
worth the risk to one
Oh dunk again nice supper manikin that
was a huge risk from JDC are you still
able to finish out that combo the wall
helping him out a little bit
Wow back to completely whip he almost
has that back to banana can't get it get
the first game again this is loser
bracket action in the top eight
somebody's definitely going home
radius Red Bull Anakin Anakin said it
ain't gonna be me though it ain't gonna
be me though alright JD see you're going
right back in there's not too many times
well JD Sierra takes too much things the
goals and like switches of stage when he
thinks about it he'll still go back to
the same state Emily and so many people
of course want both of these guys to win
you know huge fan favorites but right
now Anakin with the lead 1 to 0 JD
Sierra needs to change something up
right now and he's sticking with dragon
number I love it like no hesitation he's
like I don't have anything this is my
best pitch this is the one I did all the
work to finish under the launcher early
on and he's gonna get the wall this time
around drops a combo not too close while
rising want +2 get it gets the wall
split not goal America mannequin gonna
pick it up there's this cool attack Wow
still has a chance not you more down to
first round game 2
that's JD CR
manna and daddy's time he's so hard to
pick up on sometimes you'll see him I
just stand there and other times just
dashing in your face repeatedly you know
like as a competitor I've heard multiple
players say that like this is so hard to
catch on to end its timing and that's
pivotal in a fight sidewalk once again
getting to launched and it has gone
through so much so few down back one and
that them just like suck them up duffles
you got it look at the offense from JDC
are turning it up he's a trade zone
Anakin that is starting to fight back
start come on defense right now at that
time no block a sliver of life left
oh wow you say yeah I'll just pumping
the brake just holding back this time
around
and can having a much more difficult
time opening up JDC are at this game
jackhammer once again for - oh wow
attention um advance before it gets the
full launch was a good down for two from
JD CR yeah that walls if you know
lowlife enrage what is Anika gonna do
the second game belongs to JDC are
putting it down to to close it out GD
looking sharp there
Briggs him right back three round
straight and that defense from Annika
you were talking about kind of like fell
apart towards the Lord in that blocking
to successful lolz that last one opening
them up and now you see JD C are taking
it to a final game here for both of them
it's gonna be hard when to decide I want
to see what Anakin does now we've seen
the adjustment come from JD CR what's
the next move interesting make you heard
the leather on the glove
oh sorry
- the good man oh wow it's just the
string down to once again good often so
far from Anakin here every month more
success the previous please Jesus
overloaded now the jackhammer mixes
Lukens come to play Santa for to stop
the approach lifesteal in favor of JDC
our and trying to find an opening
yeah they're definitely like three dovey
layers ahead of each other yeah they are
they're definitely playing they just
keep outpacing each other every time and
it resets and they go back to the boots
we get to toke back at you both both of
them got attacked
like literally identical 15 seconds left
on the clock
oh my gosh tiny sliver it get them with
the downfall of the mint and sense of a
five round one game for you to Anakin Oh
jackhammer one check up on the legs he's
feeling confident 50% already oh oh
you're going to do heart right now man
back it up JB's y'all with the rage man
so much damaged check your legs again
great option for mannequin dennis is up
that but now JT charge he needs to get
this round he needs to find a way to get
this round for us Anika's gonna have a
huge lead to try to close it out in a
limited JT shirt from the tournament
how is JT are gonna make this comeback
right now he's got the tiny pixel blue
stuff set point for antique air right
now
and rent the third round oh yeah oh yeah
this is for you Harada back - is the
jackhammer while standing for Santi to
the lead right now and this is to stay
alive in the tournament if JD CR cannot
make something that he's gonna be going
home JD's in big-time trouble right now
and him looking to close it out he
smells the blood in the water keeping
the pressure back I'm not gonna happen
rain is redbull Anakin eliminate JD CR
for the twt finals 2019 and look at that
look and then we have a us a
representative still alive
loser side but still alive JDC arse
gonna go home but guys do me a huge
favor
here make some noise for Jay Dee see oh
huge fan favorite of course JDC are
going out here at seventh place in the
tournament and you mentioned it we still
have a US Representative in here and I
don't think a lot of people would have
expected that right I mean if you really
think about those the US and then to
Japan and Korea know Pakistan either
that's it look am i right I think that's
what I'm pretty sure that I'm pretty
sure you're correct right there
I mean anakim playing phenomenal not
only throughout the entire year but
right now I mean he did a great job even
in that group play I mean it started off
not so well but look at what it did for
him he's still alive here but also
somebody else who did amazing and group
play all son all son was one of those
people I felt like we talked about
ranked you going under the radar and
even Chickering a little bit Olson is
one of the prime examples of people
forgetting about just how good how
godlike up a player he is
he played amazing in the group play and
here we talked about earlier you know
yeah I'm a Germany he wanted that
tournament there goes to BAM and he'd be